all right ladies well this show
i think has given us everything we want
in a reality show we've got drama
this is not writing we've got dragons
and even a little romance
i gotta get right into it vanjie cameron
what the hell's going on if you
watched my interview with hay queen from
years ago i always said i thought pantry
was cute if
you had to kai kai with anyone it would
be
mangy does she have to say her name
while we do it i don't know
i guess you'll just have to watch and
find out because i honestly forgot what
happened
well you saw the little trailer we were
kissing we
you know we adopted sometimes you need a
little kid
i know i was shocked but that's just
because
i think of like these girls it's like my
sisters and coworkers
and i have to be like deep in the hole
to want to put my tongue down my
sister's throat you know
i wasn't shocked i think i could say
cameron who's probably my closest friend
in the show
is very much so a hopeless romantic she
really is
i would say that's very true um always
looking for
i don't want to say the next x miss
michaels but you know they always end up
being that way but
maybe this one will work out i don't
know banji is just
do whatever i want when i want type of
person so
something like that was maybe bound to
happen i think it's great i think it's
beautiful i'm excited
to see whatever journey that is i mean
evie you got a front row
it's a journey okay because evie you got
a front row seat to what was brandy
so it's like now vanji's given us two
drag race relationships in this run it's
kind of wild
she likes them tall and she likes them
flexible apparently
wow good job all right yes i do
you need somebody that could bend me up
like a pretzel wetsuit
and wait but wait if they flex with that
guy with me
uh yeah tall flexible make me feel fishy
okay we've got the [ __ ]
brooklyn commented on the trailer and
asked who's the better kisser so who's
the better kisser
we've got six episodes to see where this
thing goes i am very excited to watch it
five nights a week rupaul's drag race
live here we go
derek i feel like you're getting to live
out your fantasy because i remember
when we talked for all stars five you
said i realize i am
a reality star a reality personality oh
i've been ready for this since i moved
to vegas in 2004.
i really do feel like the last 15 plus
years has just prepped me
for this moment and it's everything i
wanted and i'm the only one from
allstars five
in the show
[Laughter]
you may have gone home first but you get
more screen time now so
yeah and not in a competition and that's
what i love about
this is it's really highlighting all of
our talents and it's giving people a
backstage look into our lives i mean
that's what really the fans want to see
the most
is what goes on behind the curtain what
goes on backstage what goes on when you
go home at night does any of you have
any trepidation or fear
in showing your real life on tv
for the first time i didn't i didn't get
a chance to showcase
a lot of my just my show self even on my
season so the fact that you get to see
me in a show
and get to see part of my real life is
like just a blessing to me that i get to
you know
show my fans and show the audience that
because i didn't really get to
portray that on my season so i i'm fully
i'm there for it i'm ready let's go
so cameron loved the camera
camera michael i think everybody but
derek here has been profiled in the work
the world docu-series naomi how would
you say this show is different from what
we've seen on work the world
on work the world i'm not necessarily a
huge fan of being on camera
because we are traveling in like a tour
bus and we're waking up in a new city
and there's so many other things to
worry about then like hi
i'm naomi smalls i can't you know it's
that's just not how my brain works so
i think that being in one place being
comfortable
like having a set stage just had a lot
more
reliability that i'm into and i love the
whole like no competition
being featured on the show because i
don't want to put my drag into a
competition ever again
and i'd rather just like compete in my
head with the girl's legs backstage
i didn't say she was the weakest lady i
think you did can i talk today on me
whoa it's nice for people to get to see
like us as individuals and get to see
how we are outside of the competition
aspect of it
and so that's really what the show is it
really is
following us getting ready for what i
think is the hardest thing we've done
when it comes to drag evie would you
agree that the vegas review is bigger
and
more intense and harder to pull off than
drag race oh yeah definitely
a it's a live show and there's no like
redos there's no oh
cut we can retake that you can't stop a
live show
and b it's such a different experience
than i believe drag queens
um are often used to working with
because
we usually are like directors producers
like writers we do our own hair and
makeup
and with this show it really was like a
lot of
being a part of an ensemble would you
guys agree
yes yeah no
why not why not well i haven't been on
all-star so i can't speak to that
we're in a competition setting you have
to think of like so many other
variables than the performance you're
doing on stage
it was cool to like have a bond with the
group before going into this setting i
loved having that familiarity rather
than like stepping into drag race and
having to deal with a bunch of strangers
but there is still a lot of drama the
trailer teases asia seems to storm off
i'm entitled to be upset
this is ridiculous asian moved out of
the dressing room
what goes down well there's a bunch of
queen you know
it's gonna happen it is what it is
that's life well of course there's six
queens so there's gonna be drama you
would think
going into this because we're not
competing that there would be
um less tension between one another
clearly we will find out really quick
that that's not the
case [ __ ] are gonna be [ __ ] who
was the biggest [ __ ] asia
um what asia
i don't think there is a biggest i think
most of us
have our moments i think asia has a big
personality
anytime you have a big personality in
drag we've seen it on seasons of drag
race
that's not always easy for big
personalities
to blend and mesh well and so i think
that
it's just really going to be exciting to
see unfold
flamingo las vegas is proud to present
[Music]
[Applause]
what is going to surprise the drag rice
fans about
the vegas review show i think it's just
simply getting
to see us in a new light getting to
not only see us as people who like are
putting on a show but
they get the biggest peak behind the
curtain and you get to
see who we really are and who we were
before we
even became professional drag queens i
guess you get to see a more raw of a
side of us
and for longer than just a snippet so i
think that's going to surprise people to
find out who these [ __ ] really are
right and the show is really about us as
people
and and our lives and how that plays
into our drag
and not the other way around and so um i
think people are going to be surprised
to see
a lot of different layers and facets of
our lives that they didn't know
existed a or b they didn't know affected
our drag so much
and that that's the whole purpose of
business for people to get to know us
as people and to get to understand why
our drag is important and relevant to us
and why some aspects of our drag are the
way that they are